the new technology used to track down
the alleged Golden State killer could
help identify another infamous serial
murderer in California a judge yesterday
ordered Joseph D'Angelo to provide his
fingerprints and additional DNA samples
to police
you must also let them photographed his
entire body Carter Evans is in Los
Angeles with how the DNA techniques used
to identify D'Angelo could help solve
other cold cases Carter good morning
good morning before the Golden State
killer's crime spree Californians were
terrorized by another killer the Zodiac
killer now investigators are hoping to
use the same methods to solve that crime
by putting the killer's DNA into a
genealogical database the cryptic in
taunting notes the Zodiac killer sent to
police and newspaper reporters may prove
to be his undoing detectives are now
trying to recover DNA from the stamps
and envelopes he used to mail those very
letters saliva has an enormous amount of
DNA it's like a liquid DNA source one of
the best sources that we have DNA expert
Monte Miller a former crime scene
investigator says a viable DNA profile
can be extracted from decades-old
evidence if it was stored safely and
kept in good condition that genetic data
once uploaded to a public genealogical
website can help locate potential
relatives investigators study the family
trees and zero in on possible suspects
through a process of elimination
you could perhaps find a granddaughter
or a cousin or a brother or someone of
that nature just like they did with the
Golden State Killer exactly like what
they did there Jim Jax has spent most of
his career on the Zodiac task force
hunting the man who fifty years ago
terrorized Northern California the
Zodiac killer boasted about killing as
many as 37 people there has not been a
lot of new information developed over
the last several years that I'm aware of
so this has a lot of potential
absolutely there's the potential is is
great he cautions any DNA recovered will
only point to whoever licked the stamps
or envelopes and not necessarily the
killer but it would still be a big break
in the case
put you to a certain geographic area
it'll help us determine where the
suspect lived you know he may have their
evidence buried in the backyard of one
of his former residences who knows now
critics worry police are essentially
turning these genealogical websites into
criminal DNA databases but Monte Miller
says he doesn't see anything wrong with
that he really hopes that more people
would voluntarily upload their own DNA
to these databases so more cold cases
could be solved John Carter thanks